do you guys know somebody that's had an
abortion
yes I'm so starting here go around in
the second row and then what was their
experience like or your experience if
you want to share go ahead
um yeah I have
I definitely have and
um
from the outside looking in it doesn't
look very it's obviously it's an
emotional it's an emotional thing to go
through I wouldn't
wish that situation in a hole on anybody
because it is and it must be a tough
decision very tough decision to make
assigned to watch people go through
stuff like that so did you say you had
one yourself I've seen you've seen one
so what was the reason they had one
um
probably just like to be fair I don't
live their life so I don't really know
what they was really going through to be
fake people only choose to tell you what
they want you to know so from what I do
know
um
I don't think it was the right time for
them or something like that okay yeah
great time okay go ahead
yeah same here I've I've seen quite a
few of my friends going through it and I
feel like as soon as you stop speaking
about it that's when you start realizing
there's actually more women than you
think that actually go through it each
year is actually crazy and
um it's something that it's actually
hard to pick a side actually for me I
was like pro-life pro-choice is
something that I understand both parts
and I feel like it's just depending on
the person their situation there's a lot
of things to take into account
so it's actually a tough decision and
it's it's something really hard to go
through definitely okay what was the
reason they had one
some people don't mention the reasons I
think is something very like
intimate-ish so that friend didn't
didn't tell you why no I had one not
necessarily yeah but most the time it's
because it's bad timing wrong person
personal I know like Financial issue
this type of things definitely okay bad
timing in person go ahead
um I'm pretty agree with you Cleo for me
I would say the most earliest abortion
news was from one of my friends
and it was in high school obviously it
was too early for her to you know to
have the baby and she had to do the
abortion and that's one of the reason I
support
I mean kind of in the middle but if I
have to use one I go for a pro choice
but luckily
um her boyfriend that time would stay
with her all the all the process so it
wasn't too bad so he was he was like
support did he want it too
um I think both of both of them um
didn't want didn't want the baby okay it
was too early okay got him
okay
um so yeah uh once
and I actually understand her very much
because
um
she had been like a fantastic mother to
two other children
and so she already had two she had two
children
um and she had sort of sacrificed her
education and sort of moving forward in
life and then she met this guy who just
knew that like we are perfect for each
other but she was very uncertain
and then
um she became pregnant after a month but
then like she had two other children and
she wanted to and the two other kids
were sorry I'm just they were not here
okay yeah okay but she was like and then
she chose to take care of the children
that she had instead of bringing in like
another child I actually think it was
twin so it would have been like two
other people
um and she told me kind of like a little
bit shameful and I think she felt very
relieved when I said like oh I
understand you and I don't think she had
gotten that reaction from other people
before yeah okay
um so what was her reasoning just like
she didn't want two different dads or
she didn't think she could take care of
the kid money money yeah yeah I mean
they were living in like a basement flat
and she was sort of
her entire life revolved around
um her two children like she couldn't
afford bringing in two other kids yeah
like for having four children and and
then I mean she didn't want to you know
risk having another dad leaving again
you know okay yeah what about you yeah I
know loads I think I mean one in three
women in our country has an abortion in
their lifetime so all of us know tons
and it's way more common than people
realize so yeah I know people who have
had an abortion who thought it was the
right decision I know people who have
had an abortion and then ended up being
pro-life activist I know people that
have done abortions you know as doctors
or whatever so yeah it's extremely
common and everyone reacts in different
ways as we've seen already
yeah like comes at so many to
specifically come to mind I guess one
who was at 19 one who was 35 uh so 19
year old uh girl really heartbreaking uh
story in that she ended up doing
performing her own abortion at home uh
through the pills by post scheme that's
now available in the UK that abortion
providers can just send at pills by post
and she did through oh really they send
you abortion by mail here exactly wow so
this started in the pandemic and it's
now continued on past the pandemic so
she had a really terrible experience and
now um she's actually yeah has joined
and a more pro-life stance and another
35 was was more similar in that she she
already had kids and she was looking to
take a step up in her career so that was
more she was more of a stable situation
but but made that choice
okay go ahead
um I don't know anyone personally but
then sometimes I actually think maybe I
do know someone that's had it but
they haven't been vocal about it because
obviously I mean there is still the
stigma with abortion which I personally
think there shouldn't be I think it
should be
what you do with your body is your
choice really I think there should be
more stigma really yes so we're we're
completely different yeah very different
we should have the most stigma yeah okay
so very interesting so completely yeah I
think I think we should stigmatize it
more okay interesting yes but it's okay
keep going keep going so yeah so I don't
I don't personally know anyone
um but again maybe there is someone that
I know that's close to me that I just I
just didn't tell you yeah exactly I I'm
I'm not sure but yeah but so as far as
you know as far as I'm concerned no but
but it could have it could have happened
yeah one out of three is a big it's yeah
it's exactly okay go ahead
um I know quite a few people that have
had abortions
um I've got friends that have had
abortions and then regretted it
um which is awful to see
um
and I've had friends that are completely
against it
and
um
part of them and I can see that part of
them
want to be
they they wanted to get an abortion
because they I've been in a in what I
meant by I'm in the middle is there's so
many it just all depends there's so many
situations like
um one of my friends in particular
um
she's in an extremely toxic situation
didn't have the memes didn't have you
know the
work there was no uh stability there is
no
um
thought so she was in like a toxic
relationship extremely toxic
relationship but not just a relationship
a whole like the life a lifestyle
everything
um
and what I'd like what's worse bringing
a baby into an extremely knowing that
it's extremely toxic situation
um
and this child not being able to live
and be a child and or um spend their
life
um affected mentally emotionally and
then they have to spend the rest of
their life struggling through therapy
and
um
trying to heal off after all this mess
and and then she she feels guilty about
it right
um or to
get an abortion I would say the second
and yes the second so I I this is why I
really do think it depends and I think
it's every situation is different I
think ones especially that is going to
it's like it's it's apparently it's
supposed to be about saving
um like pro-life saving the trail but
pro-choice could also save a child from
a lifetime I just but the way I think
about it like I think it'd make more
sense to tell women don't date toxic Men
and don't put yourself in that situation
you said or you didn't but it's like why
are you in that situation to begin with
you know what I mean yeah well I agree
but there's um there was also one of the
people that I know that got an abortion
was a drug addict
and she was
and when I say drug addict I mean
full-on
heroine and all of that and she knew she
couldn't stop it she knew she wanted to
stop it but she got pregnant and she
wanted to keep the baby and what what I
don't you know there's people like that
that um
I agree with but then I also hear
stories but then I say get off of drugs
oh I'd say get off with drugs I'd say
stop dating in that waste man but it's
it's like we agree yeah we're on the
same this is why I'm like
I don't have a no and a yes it's it all
depends okay it all depends okay what
about you
I feel like I do know uh women that have
had an abortion however they haven't
told me as they're going through it I
think it's something that they probably
only maybe share with
you know people that are really close to
there more
you know maybe other women or something
but
um I've had people tell me that you know
that they've had it's happened to them
in the past they've made that decision
you know in the past
um however I suppose the reasons have
been already mentioned today you know it
could be because they're young
it could be because
they're not with the right person you
know they might not feel like they're
gonna get adequate financial support
what do you think about it who's the
right person someone that's going to
support you well I would think like most
people like I mean you'll be surprised
if half of us are getting divorced
anyway it's like most people are with
the wrong person anyway but you know
what I hear you however like some people
the relationship doesn't work out
however they still do their best for
their child but some people they don't
care and begin with they never cared and
those are the people shouldn't be having
kids yeah well I just think that's like
the woman's fault yeah because why'd you
pick him you know what I mean the thing
is yeah I agree with you I agree with
you I agree with you 100 like it's the
women however sometimes men present
themselves in a certain way and it's a
facade well I think then you should you
know so some women they they get tricked
well I think maybe we should probably
you know then take longer to like sleep
100 yeah do you do you think really
taken that no no no no they say 50 wait
hold I found a new staff 50 of women do
do not wear a condom with a new partner
it's crazy that's crazy because it's not
just a baby you can get diseases from
that as well that's just crazy 50 it's
actually 53 if we're gonna go a little
yeah anyways go on what about you it's
also gross on the men's part I'm gonna
be honest um it's more around the women
though I would put it way more on the
women yeah it's both gross um so yeah I
I do have a story and I hope that this
will endear me to the pro-lifus a little
bit because it's a personal story not me
but my mum had an abortion
and
um she had announced the pregnancy to
all of her kids she was intending on
keeping it
however
um this was a while back and I was a kid
as well we didn't have access so a good
access to the internet or at least my
mom didn't know how to use it too good
so my mom had all of her kids in her 30s
but by this point she was now 40 and she
had been I guess scared that by the
increasing statistical chance of down
syndrome
now my mom's friend had a kid with Down
Syndrome so she went to see her friend
she spoke to her about it a bunch and in
the end she decided that if that was
going to be the end result that she
couldn't manage
she did have four kids already
um but if she had been able to know or
someone had actually told her that the
statistical likelihood of having a child
with Down Syndrome
was incredibly low just because it's
increased she'd had a healthy kid two
years before
I think she would have kept
the kid because we were she wouldn't
have announced it to all of her children
otherwise so I do think and I I was
excited I only have brothers so I was
like heck yeah this will be my sister
finally I was like to my mom
can I name it if it's a girl this so it
wasn't a happy situation it wasn't done
lightly and I do think it was done
um
sadly considering that it was based out
of being scared and not having that
information that she might have made a
different decision otherwise do you
think the doctors pushed her to do it no
they didn't push her but by providing
the statistics were saying there's an
increased chance it's not telling you
how still how small that is especially
if you've just had a child two years
prior and all of your children have been
healthy it's just what'd your dad think
about it
um so this was not my dad um I have one
brother and then I have two half
Brothers
um I think they were both sad about it
it wasn't it wasn't
um yeah it wasn't a decision that was
taken lightly
yeah so this is why I think abortion
should be banned I would ban it no
exceptions well I'm definitely not okay
with the lack of information and I do
think that sometimes
people get scared because they're like
oh if you haven't had a kid by 35 then
it's a geriatric pregnancy
um but we should be evaluating these
things on a case-by-case basis fertility
is a whole other thing and it's you know
you shouldn't be scaring people out of
what might be otherwise healthy
pregnancies if they actually want to
keep them because the majority of
abortions are had by women that already
have children
60 percent
wow you think they'd keep them then they
already did the first to my mom's case
yeah it was not talking about your mom
I'm just talking about I think usually
when it's mothers that are having
abortions it may be because they they
think they can't cope I think it's less
money and it's more coping if you've got
two or three or in my case my mom's case
four kids and then she's thinking it
might be disabled as well you start to
think oh I can't cope I'm gonna like die
from stress like I'm gonna fall apart
um obviously that's not necessarily the
case
um and it can come from you know not
feeling like you have enough support one
way or the other
um but I think it usually comes from
being scared in some way
yeah but I just think we have like a
better quality of living than we've had
in all of human history generally
speaking but I think after a certain
point you don't get any additional like
child tax credits and benefits Beyond is
it the third child
yeah but then but then like my answer is
get married stay married yeah
um well
that that that's dependent on whether or
your husband is successful at taking
care of you and to be fair on men you
might be able to happily support two
kids but four five six just might be out
of your budget right and I know that's a
tough thing to say but I don't think
money should be a predominant factor in
deciding this but it is a factor for
some people as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible